the most popular game on Steam right now
lets you throw a magic ball to capture
creatures that you then train to fight
for you and it's not Pokémon but while
many are enjoying the Nintendo free
experience others are questioning the
merits of the game itself while some are
calling it a lazy asset flip some are
going so far as to say it's
[Music]
theft pow world is the newest darling to
take the Gaming Community by storm to
the tune of over 6 million copies sold
in just under a week so what the hell is
it well on first glance it's an
adventure game where you get to wander
around an open world capturing Pals with
your pal sphere to level them up for
battle if you're thinking wait that kind
of sounds a bit like Pokemon that's
because it's exactly like Pokémon the
only twist is that PO world has guns
where are you going look at him look at
him oh Tan's got a gun he has the gun
he's got a
gun now if you look past the obvious
Pokemon similarities you'll find out
that this game is actually very similar
to well like five other games as well it
has the survival and crafting mechanics
of Arc rust and pretty much every other
game in the genre right now and its
movement in combat is basically a copy
of genin impact which itself is a copy
of breath of the wild point is power
world is like a lot of different games
what it manages to do uniquely is smash
them all together where you get this
product where you can build a castle to
shelter all your creatures before
strapping them with artillery cannons
and setting them off to battle the
concern over power world is just how
closely it decides to borrow from other
games and exactly how it was done yes
plenty of games take from each other and
practically nothing can be original
anymore but at what point does
inspiration become plagiarism when you
first hop into pal worlds it definitely
feels like a budget version of breath of
the wild motifs and all but once you get
deeper in there are enough mechanics to
set separate the game enough so the
gameplay comparisons are less egregious
however it's those Pokémon trappings the
ones that ironically make it unique that
have become the source of the online
Firestorm now if you have spent any time
online you would know exactly how the
pro Nintendo and anti- Nintendo camps
feel about each other Nintendo has done
a lot of anti-consumer over the
years to cause outrage but people who
blindly look past those issues will
defend them to the grave but honestly
that's a story for an entirely separate
video but even as an outsider someone
who isn't caught up in taking sides in
this war it's hard to argue that the
designs of these so-called Pals aren't
at least a little bit suspect to put it
bluntly these things look like Pokémon
it's to the point where people have not
only made entire threads comparing the
two but some have even noticed that the
3D models of certain Pals look like just
slightly altered versions of their
Pokémon counterparts and the more you
look at these comparisons the more it
starts to become uncanny and maybe even
blatant on the other side of the
argument you have pretty much people who
don't give a they see Nintendo is
nothing but an evil Corporation so
anything that they even partially own is
fair game now I'm not saying that
Pokémon is the only franchise allowed to
do Monster collecting and I hate
Nintendo as much as the next person but
let's beuing real here these things are
a little bit on the nose for this reason
those who have been critical of power
world success have suggested that the
developers either used AI or lazy asset
flips that should be considered
plagiarism now I want to make it clear
at this point that there is no evidence
that the developer pocket pair actually
used AI to make anything in this game as
for the asset flip accusations I have my
own opinions but I'm going to let
everyone else be the judge for
themselves but just for the sake of
context I do think it's important to
bring up that pocket pair does have
another game called craftopia a game
that has seen plenty of its own
controversy for a myriad of things
including the fact that well if you
thought power world was like breath of
the wild this one is even more of a
clone point is pocket pair doesn't have
the greatest reputation when it comes to
originality but honestly speaking I
think that's by Design and they know
exactly what they're doing in my opinion
they took two very popular IPS in Zelda
and Pokemon that are historically
exclusive to Nintendo systems and
essentially made their own version by
combining the two and making it
available on PC and gamers are eating
that up which is why I don't think
the real question is whether or not
power world ripped off Pokemon or any of
these other games I think it's pretty
safe to say at this point that it's not
the most organic thing on the market
right now the real question is whether
or not people care listen Nintendo and
the two other owners of the Pokémon IP
are probably sitting down right now
deciding whether or not they want to
seek legal action but Pokémon is already
a billion dooll franchise so they might
not care enough to have a legal battle
right now and the devs of power world
seem pretty confident that they're in
the clear so we'll just have to wait and
see how things progress but legal
dispute or not power worlds has become
one of the best selling games in Steam
history despite not being all that
original and as people like asmin gold
pointed out maybe this just proves that
Gamers don't actually care about these
things like originality AI art or asset
flips as long as the product is fun
listen I don't personally like the game
that much it just feels like something
I've already played a thousand times
before and the novelty of the Pokemon
with guns is funny but it wore off
pretty quickly for me and I don't love
the idea of us trending down this path
where developers opt out of making
something truly unique to make something
that is just going to get attention even
if it requires doing a little bit of
cheating now this isn't to say that
power worlds has no shred of identity at
all it's a wacky goddamn time and a lot
of people are enjoying it and that
brings a smile to my face so let me pass
it off to hear how you guys feel what do
you think about this entire situation do
you think that people are being unfair
do you think po world is a blatant
ripoff and if so when does fun Factor
outweigh
originality the game is like 15
different games in one though like it's
that if there's one thing we can credit
them for it's just like they're like
we'll put this in yeah it's like you
guys are going to be caught up in
illegal battle so long